he is treating migrants human beings
babies children Elders he's treating
them like Freight like a political plant
there's nothing of Goodwill about what
this man is doing so you asked me before
um if there was more communication where
I started to say Governor respect these
people as human beings
it's March first man it's March 1st
already
2023 where is the time of going I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals if you have not subscribed at
rumble.com
Reuben report go ahead and do that would
ya and if you want to join us for the
post game show where you can add
commentary and queries and much more
join us at reubenapport.locals.com a
very important note for today's show my
parents have been visiting for the last
few days and they're downstairs watching
the kids right now and my mom said to me
before I came upstairs she said how
about no cursing today but you're not
curse on the program today and then
we're doing the rundown and I realized
we got nothing from The View today we
have no clips of The View
we have no clips from MSNBC
I'm pretty sure I can get through this
show without either cursing at somebody
or having to write down what I really
think of them this is a very exciting
program I'm saying we're going to go to
a 9-7 today we shall see uh the theme
though right off that uh cold open that
we just showed you there it's very
exciting because uh Lori Lightfoot
the mayor of Chicago is no more she lost
yesterday at lost by a lot and we are
going to connect Lori Lightfoot to what
has happened to Modern liberalism and
the fight that these last few Lives who
get a couple things right but most
things wrong that they are having with
the with the woke radical progressives
and how that has really just decimated
the entire party and that if you are a
roughly sane person there is an option
there is an off ramp and you might have
to go like this and you know just jump
in and see what happens and find out
that those crazy people on the right who
you thought were bigots and racists and
homophobes and all of those things that
they're actually not that bad so there
are some options for your friends who
are still a little confused that's what
we're going to be doing today before we
get to it real quick let me talk to you
about Birch gold uh you know despite the
U.S blowing through the 31 point 0.4
trillion
that's trillion with a t dollar debt
ceiling in January the leftist White
House still refuses to reduce spending
while our national leadership has buried
their heads in the sand when it comes to
fiscal responsibility it's time to pull
yours out now would be a great time to
diversify into gold with Birch gold in
times of high uncertainty and
instability gold is King it's Dependable
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or a 401k into an IRA and precious
metals here's what you got to do visit
birchgold.com Dave today to claim your
free info kit on gold and then talk to
one of their precious metals Specialists
think about this to dig our country out
of this mountain of debt every single
taxpayer in America would have to write
a check for 247
000 and it's only getting worse protect
yourself with gold today by visiting
birchgold.com Dave they've got an A-Plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews go to
birchgold.com
Dave and now back to me okay so here's
how we are going to present the show
because we are going to give you
it this is a double whammy we're really
doing for you people not only are we not
showing you anything of the view and
MSNBC but we're going to also show you
some of Lori lightfoot's Greatest Hits
right I mean and trust me this lady has
got some greatest freaking hits an awful
lot of murders under her watch too which
we're going to get to in just a moment
uh but
the way I want to frame this show really
is we can always just hit the woke right
and we hit them hard and hopefully more
and more people are waking up to the
nonsense and all that but there still is
a problem with this sort of average
modern Democrat you guys get it and I
know I play a lot of Clips at Bill Maher
but he was on CNN yesterday with Jake
Tapper and he was making sense and the
question is can you make sense and then
vote the wrong way if you make sense and
then always vote the wrong way are you
doing something that's net good or not I
think that's the position that say a mar
a Barry Weiss your aunt Edna who
considers herself an old school Democrat
like that's the situation that these
people find themselves in so I want to
show you a quick clip this is uh Bill
Maher on CNN with Jake Tapper Bill Maher
by the way they're doing real time his
extra segments that they used to just
air on YouTube are now on CNN so he's in
a bit of a partnership with with CNN I'm
just putting that out there just for
transparency but here's Mar making some
sense on CNN with Jake Tapper I think
it's this collection of ideas that are
not building on liberalism but very
often undoing it
I mean five years ago Abraham Lincoln
was not a controversial figure among
liberals we liked him
now they take his name off schools and
tear down his statues really Lincoln
isn't good enough for you
um you know five ten years ago
Bedrock liberalism was we are striving
to be a colorblind Society where we
don't see race
um of course we see it but it doesn't
matter
that's not what woke is woke is
something very different it's it's
identity Pockets we see it all the time
it's always the most important thing I
don't think that's liberalism I mean I
could mention so many issues like that I
remember doing
um that show on HBO uh comic relief for
the homeless and
the idea then again among liberals I
thought was you know for the sake of
compassion can we get these people off
the street so they have a roof over
their heads and now it's like how dare
you try to move the homeless this is
where they live it's like again you
change the definitions and then you say
I'm more conservative I believe what
I've always believed you changed these
things and then you yell at me for it
okay so sanity and Sanity no matter who
it comes from is nice to hear every now
and again now there's a couple
interesting things there he's right that
it's the liberals who used to want to be
colorblind but it's the modern liberals
who are the walksters right like he's in
an
increasingly shrinking set of people
that seem unable to control any of the
people around them right the whole house
is burning and they're looking at the
Dust Bunny in the corner going oh we
better deal with that Dust Bunny but the
whole house is burning because of the
wokes of the walksters and I think that
this and this is a depressing thing I've
said this before but this is a
depressing realization for me to have to
come to as someone that I think I put
the phrase Classical liberalism back in
the American lexicon more than anybody
right I mean it was seven years ago
eight years ago at this point where I
was saying hey the Liberals are not
acting liberally you guys know that but
it's a depressing reality to have to
come to the realization that the blind
spot of liberalism seems to be that
there's no emergency break right so the
Liberals used to want to be colorblind
but now they are the ones who are
obsessed with color and again there were
a couple ancillary people on the outside
going guys could we not be crazy here
anymore but in essence you should be
voting a completely different way I also
want to address that he talked about
comic relief if you guys remember comic
relief it was an annual thing that that
really all the A-list comedians did
every year on HBO it was mostly done in
I think in the 80s maybe maybe early to
mid 90s and Whoopi Goldberg hosted it in
Robin Williams and Billy Crystal and
they would get every I'm talking every
comic doing their routine and they were
you know taking money live you know
phone call calls pledges for homeless
people but it's kind of funny like now I
remember watching it back then thinking
what an incredible thing this was like
there you know it's all my favorite
people I loved comedy and stand up and
it's like all my favorite people raising
money for homeless people like this is
all good
flashback now or Flash Forward to where
we are today and it's like well we now
know that it was the Democrat policies
that created all of that homelessness
right plenty of people probably knew it
back then guys like Thomas sold knew it
back then but now knowing what I know
it's like man all of you guys you were
all liberals and lefties putting in big
government High tax High regulation
policies that caused the very condition
that then you were doing your annual
Telethon about
anyway I don't want to um just
relentlessly bash bill here because you
know I am trying because first off what
he said is right and you want to give
people credit when they say things that
are true but here's the point and here's
how I'm going to Loop this towards the
Lightfoot situation is that I want to
show you this video this is Bill Maher
on real time two days before the
midterms two days before the midterms he
spent years now fighting the woke the
Democrats are nuts the radicals are
running the party all of that stuff but
listen to his final this is as he's
ending the show his final plea to people
before they vote uh whether they should
vote Democrat or Republican and I think
you will see the problem
Ben Franklin said our country was a
republic if you can keep it well we
can't
and unless a miracle happens on Tuesday
we didn't democracy is on the ballot and
unfortunately it's going to lose and
once it's gone it's gone
it's not something you can change your
mind about in Reverse that's gender
[Laughter]
so here's what's going to happen
Republicans will take control of
Congress and next year they'll begin
impeaching Biden and never stop they'll
impeach him for getting out of
Afghanistan and getting into Ukraine for
inflation for recession for falling off
his bike it won't matter and it won't
make sense but Biden will be a crippled
duck when he goes up against the 2024
Trump carry Lake ticket
and even if Trump loses it doesn't
matter an inauguration day 2025 he's
going to show up whether he's on the
list or not
and this time he's not going to take no
for an answer because this time he will
have behind him the army of election
deniers that is being elected in four
days
there are almost 300 candidates on the
ballot this year who don't believe in
balance and they'll be the ones writing
the rules and monitoring how votes are
counted in 24. the facts the policies
the behavior don't matter anymore Hitler
was elected so was Mussolini Putin
erdogan Victor Orban
this is the it can't happen to us moment
that's happening to us right now
we just don't feel it yet
you're like I'm gonna have to text Bill
after the show and apologize but dude
you see the point there guys so the day
before two days before the election
after spending all of his time
correctly fighting the woke fighting the
radicals I'm a liberal the Democrats are
not liberal he went all in on oh my God
this is about democracy and if we don't
get the results that we want democracy
is over and the Republicans will have
these sham impeachments of Biden which
is hilarious because that clearly isn't
happening and there were two sham
impeachments and they tried they really
would have loved a third one if they
could have got there of trump so this
sort of Hysteria that you get all of the
stuff kind of right but that at the
moment of choosing when the road
officially forks and you have it right
in front of you which way do you go
which way do you go if you want a
society that is classically liberal and
believes in individual rights and some
level of laissez-faire economics and
that the government shouldn't be on top
of you all the time if you as a liberal
choose the other road because you're
afraid of being called a Republican or
something like that
then it's kinda on you and and that is a
problem and I would contrast that with
what is happening in so many of the red
states where we are expunging a lot of
this nonsense I want to show you uh and
then we'll get to the Lori Lightfoot
stuff a tweet by Chris Ruffo from
September of 21. uh Chris Ruffo you know
him from the Manhattan Institute I
reference him all the time he's helping
Governor DeSantis right here in Florida
get the woke stuff and die out of our
institutions uh this is just a couple
months ago
no I'm sorry this is about 15 months ago
um talking about the mayors of Chicago
Portland and Louisville and Boise have
officially endorsed critical race theory
in public schools and promised to drive
the Implement implementation of critical
race theory in the public education
curriculum Across America they aren't
hiding it any more so that is 15 months
ago and those are all Democrats but the
Liberals
the good liberals like Bill Maher tell
people in essence you have to vote for
all of these guys at a state level and
at a federal level because somehow
Republicans are really the mean scary
people now one of the Mayors uh who Greg
Fisher from Kentucky was there Lauren
McLean from Idaho is there Lori
Lightfoot from Illinois and Ted wheeler
you know Ted wheeler the mayor or form
is he the former mayor now of Portland
Oregon is he still is he still the mayor
I know he got kicked out of his
apartment because a crime nobody wanted
to live with him but it doesn't even
matter Portland's just a dump uh anyway
so Lori Lightfoot signed that thing so
they were bringing critical race Theory
into the schools right and we know
they're bringing diversity equity and
inclusion and they will discriminate
against white people and they will push
people up depending on skin color and
punish other people which is the exact
thing that Bill Maher was complaining
about yesterday with Jake Tapper but
he's for the candidates unfortunately
that Usher this stuff in so now let's
get to Lori Lightfoot clay Travis
updated us on what happened last night
Lori Lightfoot was crushed in tonight's
Chicago Mayoral race and didn't even
make the runoff 84 percent of Chicagoans
voted against her 84 percent that level
of incompetence is tough to pull off for
an incumbent congrats to her I mean it
really is wild so there were there were
a bunch of people running but the fact
that 84 of the people said any of these
people instead of Lightfoot is just
really incredible I will say before we
get into some of Laurie's Greatest Hits
and her concession speech that I am not
hopeful for Chicago you know generally
what happens in these democrat-run
cities is they get rid of you know they
they vote in the most radical person say
a Gavin Newsom in San Francisco or any
of the DA's right George gascon in in
Los Angeles
Chester bonid and San Francisco Ted
wheeler mayor of Portland they vote in
the absolute absolute worst all hell
breaks lose crime runs rampant the the
good decent citizens law-abiding
citizens get the hell out of there
everybody's freaking out and then what
do they do they they either recall them
or they have another election and then
they just vote in someone slightly less
worse but not really less worse so I I
don't have much hope for Chicago which
is unfortunate Chicago was once an
absolutely wonderful City and when I was
did the book tour in Chicago we had an
absolutely great time Chicagoans have an
incredible sense of humor like they're
fun and light and it just really loved
it uh anyway uh here is just a bit of
Lori lightfoot's concession speech last
night
let me just uh do this
so thank you and and thank everyone so
much I feel a lot of love in this room
as I felt every step of the way on this
journey I've called Brandon Johnson and
Paul vallas to congratulate them on
their victories in advancing uh to the
runoffs
we were Fierce competitors
and these last few months but I will be
rooting and praying for our next mayor
to deliver for the people of the city
for years to come
okay so that part was actually kind of
nice and she's stepping down with a bit
of Grace uh but it did continue and we
got some information here from the New
York Post Democratic Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot blamed racism and her gender
for her Landslide defeat in her
re-election bid as Chicagoans wary of
rising crime on her watch celebrated her
fall from political rock star to Rock
Bottom I'm a black woman in America of
course she replied when asked by a
reporter if she'd been treated unfairly
but she called being Chicago's mayor the
honor of a lifetime the way that these
people use race and gender to their
advantage and is rather extraordinary
because the people voted her in so when
they voted her in were they racist
sexist bigots
it's only after a couple years of her
leadership that suddenly they became
racist sexist bigots because apparently
it's racist sexist bigots who don't like
mass murder on the streets constantly
don't worry we've got some updated
numbers on the shootings and murders in
Chicago uh just in a sec but maybe
here's why she lost uh here's one of her
one of her greatest hits you may
remember this one
now I've directed superintendent Brown
to order all police districts to give
special attention to these parties
and this is how it's going to be
we will shut you down we will cite you
and if we need to we will arrest you and
we will take you to jail period
there should be nothing unambiguous
about that
don't make us treat you like a criminal
but if you act like a criminal and you
violate the law and you refuse to do
what is necessary to save lives in the
city in the middle of a pandemic we will
take you to jail period
and she's she's a pretty terrible person
people voted for that person
to treat them that way she wanted to
take otherwise law abiding citizens who
just did not want to listen to her
nonsense related to covid and open up
their businesses and go out and about
she was threatening to arrest them and
send them to jail and also it's the tone
with which she does it there's the anger
that she's doing it with as opposed to
like listen guys there is really a
horrific horrific pandemic out there we
do not want to have to do this but she's
doing it with anger we will exercise our
power over you we are better than you we
are the government but of course Lori
Lightfoot noted style icon Lori
Lightfoot she had to get a haircut
during covet because she's a beautiful
woman and well take a look good
afternoon you know the last thing that
mayor Lightfoot wanted to talk about
today was getting a haircut and she
didn't do a whole lot of talking about
it but she certainly didn't apologize
for it either
she's begged lashed out and used humor
to try and get people to stay at home to
stop the spread of covid19. hey babe
what's up
Ward you're saving lives
foreign but a photo that surfaced on
social media showing the mayor after
getting a trim has some asking what
about me the mayor was asked at least
twice about the haircut this afternoon
I'm out in the public eye and you know
I'm I'm a person who I take my personal
hygiene very seriously as I said I felt
like I needed to have a haircut I'm not
able to do that myself and so I got a
haircut
guys Lori Lightfoot takes her personal
hygiene very seriously this woman
brushes her teeth we're told by Insider
six to eight times a day
she's using shampoo and conditioner
never the two in one
she's washing with a lavender soap and
my god do you see this she was literally
threatening to arrest her own citizens
while she because she's out there
she it's okay for her the beauty that
she is the natural beauty I think we can
all objectively say I don't think it's
subjective but truly a beautiful woman
loved by man admired by women Lori
Lightfoot uh here she is with her wife
uh and they were calling to vax five and
eleven-year-olds I do have to just up
front say that this video was uh well
you'll see it was slightly altered by
the meme makers of the internet but the
content was not changed but you will see
one unless she was really heavy on the
makeup that day a woman that really
cares about her appearance
the covid-19 vaccines are by far the
best way to protect yourself and your
loved ones from the virus
anyone who isn't vaccinated should get
one as soon as possible to be protected
for the holidays and that includes five
to eleven-year-olds who are now eligible
for the Pfizer vaccine
you know what the hell do I know maybe
that was her without makeup remember in
the original Batman Michael Keaton
Batman when Jack Nicholson he has to put
makeup on to look like a real person
because he actually has transformed into
a clown that might be her originally I
don't know fact Checkers misinformation
Specialists please let us know uh anyway
here's another one by her I mean this
one is just wild so you guys know the
crime in Chicago is bananas murders
shootings it just never ends thousands
and thousands of people uh shot under
her watch we'll give you the numbers in
just a sec it's really crazy uh but here
she is a couple months back when a
Newsmax reporter asked her about Rising
crime in Chicago which might have
something to do with 84 percent of the
people not voting for her yesterday
mayor Lightfoot what uh I think
introduce yourself sir yes I don't think
I'm familiar with you William Kelly I'm
with Newsmax
um what I think everybody knows uh but
um you didn't mention I don't think any
of uh your speakers here today mentioned
it is the reason why the hotels are
empty the reason why the storefronts are
closed is because of fear of violent
crime uh there was well if I may ask my
question it's a simple question this uh
horrific Juneteenth 50-some shooting uh
uh 50 some shootings
a young hispanic couple pulled from
their car and shot execution style this
this video has gone viral I don't think
we've had any arrests in this case yet
question is do you feel personally
responsible for the uh your rhetoric
your your heated rhetoric is responsible
for this off the charts violent crime in
the city of Chicago you know what that's
not that's not appropriate sir if you
will turn if you look around you sir
you're surrounded by white reporter so I
I really ask you okay to do you feel
responsible let me let me answer the
question that you've already asked so I
don't know where you're from I buy I
know I know I know what I I know what
magazine you're from and I know what
your conservative viewpoints are but on
almost every question that you ask you
had the facts okay so she had the fact
the guy had the facts right but putting
that aside the fact that she's counting
which reporters are white and black and
whatever else this is also the same
woman who said you may remember this we
covered it quite extensively that she
would refuse to be interviewed by white
reporters because black reporters needed
a leg up but if you want some info on
the murders the murder and the Mayhem
under Lori Lightfoot uh here's we're
going to first break down just even
prior to Lori Lightfoot what was going
on in Chicago so here you go this is
Chicago homicides by year 99 to 2002 and
you can sort of see it there that it's
getting bigger as Lori Lightfoot took
over but in 99 it was at 642 2005 453
2010 440 2018 579 now we're in light for
with territory
2019-500 to the next year it jumped to
772 the next year it jumped to 802. now
right 2022 I guess it's a little unclear
it's 688 to 695 but here's the real
numbers that you need to know since Lori
lightfoot's term began we just fact
checked this Chicago has suffered
2278 homicides
2278 homicides and over 9
000 people shot think about that that is
bananas and Chicago has some of if not
the strictest stringest laws related to
guns in the entire country since January
1st
of this year and we're only at March 1st
the city has endured 41 homicides and
194 people shot uh that's according to
the Chicago contrarian so this woman has
done an unbelievably horrible job it's
why we know people are fleeing Chicago
it's why the police in Chicago are not
respected they have been hampered they
are retiring early this is exactly
what's happening in Portland in San
Francisco and Los Angeles and New York
City
etc etc but it's not what's happening
here in Florida and here in Florida
we're hiring the best of the best and
we're offering bonuses for good police
officers who want to come down here and
do good work and that is the blueprint
that Ron DeSantis is trying to now send
Across America as I hope you saw I
interviewed Governor DeSantis two days
ago we put it up yesterday his book
about the Florida blueprint came out
yesterday the courage to be free and
having no idea that uh Lori Lightfoot
was about to step down I asked him about
his visit because last week he went to
New York City and to Philadelphia and to
Chicago I asked him what it was like to
go to Chicago which is in just complete
stark contrast to what's going on here
let's say in Miami
so you just bounced around some of those
blue states and cities to talk about law
enforcement and a couple other things we
played a bunch of clips of you were the
local officials there maybe even the
Democrats kind of like Hey Ron thank you
for coming here and can somebody fix
this thing I mean are they secretly on
the DL rooting for someone like you to
show up and and fix things because we
just know it's not happening in these
blue cities
so it's interesting and in Chicago the
Chicago one was the most publicized
because it was with the Fraternal Order
police very powerful organization and it
had been publicized I guess like a week
in advance and so the left in Illinois
was really working a gin up protest
against me when I came so I'm pulling in
and this was like an American Legion
Hall so they had to cap it there was
capacity uh for who could get in and I'm
looking for these protesters and I'm
seeing all these people outside kind of
hooting and hollering and they all had
signs welcoming me there were some
protesters but there weren't very many
but the rest were really thankful for
that and so I think the issue is is you
know some of these politicians kowtowed
to the left the governor there some of
these people running for mayor but I
think you go underneath that and
particularly for individual voters
regardless if you're a Republican or
Democrat you know that what they're
doing is wrong isn't that the
interesting piece that last part there
it's like the average person who is not
hyper are political right they don't
really care if you're a Democrat or
Republican they just want basic Law and
Order you know a very small percentage
unfortunately of American people vote
right it's gotten a little bit better in
the last couple election Cycles because
people are so hysterical with politics
but people do want basic services to be
functioning in a city they don't want to
see literally executions in the middle
of the day there is a video we almost
showed it today but I didn't want to do
it it was going viral on Twitter
yesterday of a guy just being executed
in the middle of the street middle of
the day in St Louis like in the middle
of the city middle of it did I say
middle enough like it's just happening
in broad daylight of course democrat-run
St Louis the mayor happens to be a black
woman I don't want to you know come off
as racist by saying that you'd think she
would care it was a black guy doing the
shooting and a black guy being shot but
okay whatever doesn't matter again I
don't care about these things these are
the things they purport to care about
the race of the people actually I do
care about when people get murdered
obviously but government has this is to
say this is right he goes to these
places and they go man we just wanted
something decent here we didn't want to
have to think about politics but the
less you think about politics the more
that the left comes in and wrecks
absolutely everything I think we played
a portion of this a couple days ago but
the DeSantis crew put together a little
recap video of his trip to New York
Philly in Chicago I thought it would be
a nice cap on this before we move on we
do not surrender to the woke mob
policing in the spotlight today this
morning Florida Governor Ron DeSantis is
in New York the first of a three-city
tour in Florida our crime rate is at a
50-year low and we've done it by our
commitment to Public Safety and our
support for the men and women of law
enforcement and contrast that to what we
see in some of these other areas which
has had the polar opposite results high
crime escalating rates they are putting
woke ideology ahead of Public Safety
they are pursuing politics at the
expense of the well-being of those who
wear the uniform and I can promise you
this that in Florida we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob our state is
where woke goes to die
yeah it's just kind of as simple as that
right so like just think about listening
to Lori Lightfoot imagine if you were
one of her constituents in Chicago and
how different that is than what's
happening here now obviously he's the
governor not the mayor but but that that
actually transcends whether you're the
governor or the mayor like when you just
do the right thing and you just say what
is true you start getting better people
moving in your economy starts chugging
along you get a 50-year dip in crime so
what are the current mainstream Democrat
priorities it's clearly not crime and
safety right it just is not I don't know
maybe it's their appearance right Lori
Lightfoot she's got to get that haircut
she's a public person and she needs to
maintain that level of beauty but no it
seems like it's mostly about what they
can pretend that they're doing uh rather
than what they are actually doing so
this one is really wild so Pete bootage
and as you know Pete booty judge is our
transportation secretary with no
expertise in transportation mayor of
South Bend Indiana no offense to South
Bend small town maybe a hundred thousand
people I'm not even sure if it's that
many he had absolutely no expertise in
this but Pete uh is married to a dude
thus he gets a better job that's kind of
how it works that's what they do that's
what they promote they love diversity
Equity inclusion doesn't matter if
you're good at what you do how many
lesbians do we have in here how many
black people do we have here that's what
they love so uh Pete was being
interviewed uh and listen to his
priorities what is most important to
Pete more than anything else this is
really this is wild imagine if you ever
said anything like this I meant climate
is not nonsense dealing with climate
change is one of the biggest things that
people like me and people like him will
be remembered for after we're gone
let's put aside your feelings on climate
for just a second now I think it's 99
climate change I think is 99 complete
nonsense meaning the climate is always
changing humans figure out different
places to live we adapt we move we build
different structures Etc et cetera we
know all the Democrats the rich
Democrats like Obama Martha's Vineyard
on the water Pelosi on the water this is
what they do okay fine but he's mostly
thinking about what his legacy will be
how he will be remembered and if you
think for one second that AOC or Pete
bootage can stop or adjust Mother Nature
you are crazy these people these people
can't do anything they they actually
well they can't do anything good they
can't create anything good which is why
they've never created a business they've
never created a sustainable entity that
has employed a whole bunch of people and
helped a bunch of people flourish what
they are good at is taking money from
some people and just pushing it towards
other people and usually keep keeping
them in poverty or something like that
but he's mostly thinking about that if
he can get this done related to climate
change whatever this is right we don't
even know what this is you want aoc's
green New Deal or whatever it is that
that's what he will be remembered by
it's just it was like gross listening to
it and that that's what you it's not up
to you to decide what you will be
remembered by I I don't know I don't
know if anyone's going to remember me I
had a little Adventure here it was a
little blip in the in the radar of the
universe and uh if I'm remembered it'll
be up to somebody else not uh not up to
me uh but they seem to care about their
looks right that's what Laurie she had
to break the laws of covid because she
cares about how she looks and Pete has
to care about his legacy
of course his Legacy isn't looking so
great because he's always complaining
about uh fossil fuels
all of that stuff but he does like the
private jet because he's a Democrat he's
better than you there is an internal
audit of your use of FAA jets for
official trips following a request for
review by Senator Marco Rubio it also
can scrutinized Elaine child's private
jet uh travel as Transportation
secretary do you have a response to that
yeah here's how we handle my travel the
vast majority of the time I travel on
commercial airlines and economy class
but there is a portion of the time I'd
say about 10 to 20 percent uh when we
use our agency's aircraft this is not
chartering a private jet this is a
government aircraft that is assigned to
the FAA uh yeah it's private though
right meaning you're the guy that gets
on the plane and there's a pilot and you
got your couple people that work for you
and you do your thing
I'm not against that I'm just calling
out your ridiculous hypocrisy related to
all of these things even if first off
there's nowhere that he has to be that's
so important right he showed up two
weeks late to East Palestine and nobody
even wanted him there the idea that he
can't own if he felt it was all so
important but we know it's not really
what they feel right what happens at
Davos World economic Forum the People
John Kerry and Al Gore the very people
complaining about your carbon emissions
and what meat you eat they are taking
private jets all over the place and
there is no way that you any of you
watching this or me for the rest of my
life could ever leave the carbon
footprint that these people have left so
hypocrisy knows no bounds but what else
are the Democrats working on the big
thing yesterday
it was actually bigger than Lori
Lightfoot losing is that the Supreme
Court right now is hearing arguments I
think the argument's actually wrapped
they wrapped up yesterday if I'm not
mistaken right we don't have the answer
on it yet but the argument's wrapped up
yesterday
related to this student loan bailout
situation that basically the Biden
Administration right before the election
right before the election they said
we're going to do student loan bailouts
now there's no way I am not a
constitutional lawyer but I have spoke
to several constitutional lawyers and I
have a half a brain half a functioning
brain over here there is nothing in the
Constitution that says the president is
allowed to wipe out student debt it
simply is not in the Constitution right
and also while many people seem to think
it is such a bright thing to do you will
help poor people by right by getting rid
of student debt do you know how many
rich and upper middle class kids there
are who go to Syracuse University for 65
Grand a year 300 000 Plus in debt by the
time they get out and their debt should
be wiped too so you're going to actually
do a bailout for upper upper middle
class people now I think if you're going
to bail out anybody you bail out
everybody and you do it equally but
there is simply nothing in the
Constitution that says that they can do
this the Biden Administration knows that
but they did it right before the
election because they wanted to make
sure young people would vote then like
two days after the election you may
remember this we covered it like two
days after the election it came out that
it was being challenged then that lower
courts felt it was not constitutional
because obviously it's it's sort of like
the Roe v Wade situation there was
obviously no constitutional guarantee to
abortion it's not in the dock right it's
got to be in the dock that's what makes
it constitutional or in the Bill of
Rights right or in subsequent decisions
and this is the exact same thing there
is nothing in the Constitution that says
the president who is the executive right
he's not supposed to write laws he's
just supposed to sign them right that's
how this thing works or it's supposed to
work there's obviously nothing in the
Constitution about that we've tried to
find something pretty non-partisan to
recap what's going on here I chose NBC
News here's Lester Holt who I don't
think is particularly good he's done
some horrible hit pieces on Jordan
Peterson in the past but here's basic
information from NBC my God they can do
it every now and again good evening and
welcome everyone in a pair of cases that
will impact tens of millions of student
loan borrowers the Supreme Court heard
arguments today on whether the Biden
administration had the authority to
forgive some of those loans the
president's loan debt relief plan calls
for erasing up to twenty thousand
dollars in student loans for certain
borrowers at an estimated cost of 400
billion dollars but it was put on hold
last Fall by an appeals court today the
plan appeared to face new headwinds
before The Supreme Court as conservative
justices questioned whether the
president was acting within the law the
White House defending the plan tonight
as a helping hand for those getting back
on their feet after the pandemic but
critics say the program is patently
unfair for those who paid their debt or
who never took out a loan in the first
place
it's so interesting even the way they
frame that and that was the best NBC
could do but it's a it's a helping hand
by the Democrats but that doesn't mean
it's constitutional the conservative
justices have concerns about the law
well their Supreme Court justices they
have law clerks they're experts in law
and it's a pretty high court up there
says Supreme right The Supremes this is
pretty good
but the Democrats with their helping
hand the Democrats are just trying to
help people but those conservative
judges have concerns about it's just so
boring and ridiculous look it's simply
not in the Constitution I cannot imagine
how the judges would actually go for
this thing the president even if the
president means well I mean that's what
Lester all say the President's trying to
be nice the president doesn't want
people to have that so come on come on
anyway here is Teachers Union president
this woman my god oh
I was almost going to say something but
my mom's downstairs she made a request
this woman Randy Weingarten she's
running the teachers union she locked
kids in school she locked kids out of
school she masked kids she's just
absolutely terrible and she's a Democrat
activist pretending very poorly to be
nonpartisan she's also always going to
Ukraine which is a little bizarre to
talk about how important it is that we
help Ukraine but she's the teachers
union president here in the United
States anyway here she is in front of
the Supreme Court having a full on
psychotic episode enjoy
this is what really pisses me off during
the pandemic we understood that small
businesses were hurting and we helped
them and it didn't go to the Supreme
Court to challenge it fake businesses
were hurting and we helped them and it
didn't go to the Supreme Court to
challenge it all of a sudden what is
about our students they challenge it the
corporation's challenges the student
loan lenders challenge it that is not
right that is not fair and that is what
we are fighting as well when we say
castle so to death
you know guys
um one of the things I've really come to
believe in my old age is that if you
have a command of what you believe if
you know what you believe and why you
believe it and if you think through the
issues honestly and clearly even when
all hell is breaking loose and it always
seems like all hell is breaking loose
like you can communicate that kind of
clearly and honestly there are times
when I'm more annoyed right like you've
seen this show long enough we did that
clip a couple weeks ago where I just
dropped like eight f-bombs in one
sentence and I was genuinely like
frustrated
but these fake emotive pandering
ridiculous LARPing actions by these
people where they scream and this is
what progressives do they don't she
doesn't know why she believes what she
believes she just damn well wants it
done and why does she want it done
because she wants it done and that's
good enough that does not mean it is
constitutional lady and by the way you
were for all the closures you were for
closing the schools so now you pretend
you really care that small businesses
and big businesses were closed you were
for
all of it this woman has done more to
damage the minds and bodies of young
people in America maybe more than anyone
except for maybe I don't know Rochelle
wilinski from the from the CDC my friend
Carol Markowitz who's on the show next
week I mentioned we just did a sit down
with her on her new book which is all
about parenting in a time of covid and
all of this craziness she had wrote a
piece in the New York Post in July of 21
about Randy Weingarten I just want to
read a little excerpt because I thought
it was quite good she said if your child
didn't attend school regularly last year
Randy Weingarten is likely the reason
why last September as schools across the
country were trying to open Weingarten
could be counted on to oppose any such
move if Community spread is too high if
you don't have the infrastructure of
testing and you don't have the
safeguards that prevent the spread of
viruses in the school we believe you
cannot reopen in person Weingarten said
who can forget her interview with Jewish
Telegraph Telegram graphic agency in
March in which Weingarten lied that
virtually every school district in New
York state and in Connecticut is
reopened many of them have reopened in
New Jersey
in fact Gotham middle and high schools
ended the school year still mostly
closed while elementary schools would
only open full time at the end of April
weeks after the interview several
districts in New Jersey didn't open for
in-person school this year at all in the
same interview Weingarten took aim at
Jews who dared question why schools were
still closed Weingarten called them the
ownership class when casual Marxism with
bizarre anti-semitic undertones makes it
into the classrooms it isn't difficult
to see where it originates this woman
has been completely insane this entire
time and what she now fears is that too
many people see her Insanity she's still
in charge of those teachers unions and
she will gladly lock down kids again and
and push Matt vaxes on them and
everything else you may remember this
this is two years ago I mean this this
is as a parent now to watch a video like
this and understand what they did to
children I hated it then but now I don't
even know what to say about it this is
her two years ago saying she supports
mandating vaccinations on kids five
years old
freaking years old and up in terms of
vaccines I think what Gavin Newsom did
in California is really the best model
which is that the semester after they
are they go from emergency use to full
authorization and the FDA has done
everything that they need to do that's
what California has said that is the
semester that they become mandatory but
and you support that naturally and I and
and I I personally support that the
union hasn't taken a position on that
personally I support that and you know
because we haven't you know our
California Federation has and they
support it and you know generally I
believe that we will take that position
and
lady let me just tell you this if you
ever are saying that what Gavin Newsom
did is the best thing you got to have
your head checked you should be studied
by a team of scientists they should be
going in there cracking your skull open
and figuring out what freaking mind
virus is in there and they they gotta
send that to the lab and do something
with it so she closed down schools she
wanted to inject kids with that did
not
we're gonna count
can you check is is is that technically
a curse anymore because I'm pretty sure
you're allowed to say it like yeah it is
I'm pretty sure you're allowed to say it
on like NBC at eight o'clock sure there
goes my 97 today
anyway you got the point I don't like
her she's not very good at what she does
and and there's a reason she's
hysterical right they they love this
emotive performance because the more
they do it they they think it tricks
people into thinking that they're right
they're screaming she's screaming so
loud she's genuflecting and
she obviously is right and it's just not
true and more and more people are seeing
through it uh here's another wizard uh
this is Corey Bush he is a progressive
she is from the squad uh and mostly she
wants this thing uh passed this uh
bailout for the students uh because it
will help black people
his student debt relief plan it takes
significant steps to reducing the racial
wealth Gap and I'm going to address that
we know that black bars statistically
black women carry the heaviest through
net burden we know that black women
already struggle with wage
discrimination we earn on average 58
Cent for every dollar a white man earns
that ain't right
oh God lady uh where do we do we uh
we'll do the racial wealth Gap it's it's
complete nonsense I would recommend that
you watch Christina off Summer's video
on prageru about the gender wage Gap
it's it's complete nonsense men and
women often choose different professions
that's what happens there are many
reasons for that there's a
hunter-gatherer version of that women
generally are attending to the children
these are fundamental differences that
you may not like but they actually are
different men tend to like things so
generally would become more interested
in say engineering where women tend to
like people and to become nurses a
little bit more but when they do a
comparison of the same exact job there
is basically no gender pay Gap okay but
they wanna they wanna make sure that you
think that you know we're discriminating
against women and we're discriminating
discriminating against black people and
all of those things and it's just not
true and again
even if it was all true
even if all of that stuff was true it
doesn't mean that it's constitutionally
legal
to wipe out student debt it's not in the
dock but they don't like the doc very
much so unfortunately to now bring this
around these are the these are the same
people that a guy like Bill Maher is
telling you to vote for the day before
the election when he's basically saying
if you vote Republican you will you will
end democracy right we will end in this
Banana Republic well I know he doesn't
like Corey Bush and he doesn't accept
the woke stuff and I suspect he doesn't
really love well I was gonna say he
doesn't really love Randy Weingarten but
I'm pretty sure she's been on the show a
couple times the point is that if you
keep voting Democrat and the Democrats
and then all of their Machinery around
them the the teachers unions and
corporate media and big Tech and all
that stuff keeps pushing all the stuff
that you say that you're against ah bill
I'll text you after this it's nothing
personal you got the point they're
ruining our States they're ruining our
cities and they're just going to keep
going uh so I thought a nice way to end
the show today would be a little bit
different uh I found this video of uh
Shark Tank billionaire investor you know
this guy Mr Wonderful Kevin O'Leary uh
he was on Tucker Carlson's Fox Nation
show and he started talking about what's
happening in America it's obviously a
theme I've been talking about for quite
some time how the blue States simply are
not working anymore that if you just
want to create create something whatever
it is a business you want to sell
t-shirts you want to open up a store you
want to sell freaking smoothies that
it's just becoming impossible to do in
blue States
my whole life as an investor
30 plus years
95 of my money either went to Silicon
Valley
or into Boston around MIT and Harvard
that was the birthplaces of venture
capital since 1954.
that's where it all went
you can't put money to work in either of
those places today
Massachusetts is at war with
entrepreneurship
Elizabeth Warren will punish you for
Success she will make sure you pay super
taxes if you're successful the
regulatory environment there is
prohibitive for business New York
even worse New Jersey forget about it
California is not in business you can't
do business there and they're leaving
like droves out of there so this
competition of states is beginning to
occur it's really really interesting now
now Kevin O'Leary is is Canadian
originally uh did he end up running for
conservative uh party I think he might
have actually run in the conservative
party and it actually didn't do that
well but this is this billionaire guy uh
who's telling you hey I used to dump all
my money
to the Boston area the Harvard area and
to Silicon Valley and you cannot do it
these are places you no longer can do
business in I don't know if you guys saw
it yet but if you haven't seen it part
one of my interview with Peter Thiel
another billionaire uh is is up right
now on YouTube the full thing's already
on uh on locals and he talks about that
too that doing business in these places
is becoming impossible if you want to be
taxed to High Health thus punished while
Elizabeth Warren of course Senator fake
Native American senator from
Massachusetts she somehow has become
worth you know I think something like a
hundred million dollars sent all her
kids to private school she doesn't want
to do that
um in any event they they punish success
and they make sure that people can't
bring new capital in so even think about
it now if you're looking at the general
state of the states and you're going
well it does seem like New York's kind
of banged up right now and Cali is kind
of banged up in Massachusetts Jersey
okay they're banged up right now but you
know these things are cyclical it'll
come around but you know what they need
to come around is you need people to
come in and over time they have to fix
things right things don't get fixed over
over one cycle right over one year
it gets fixed over a long period of time
who in their right mind right now is
looking at those places and being like
yes I'm going to build a giant Factory
in New York I'm going to employ all of
these people in California as he said
California is just done so they just
keep moving and they keep moving and
then they take resources they take it's
not just money they take good people
that's what my lesson the lesson of my
life more than anything else in the in
the 15 or so months that I've been here
in Florida has been that from all of the
people I've met and the people that came
with me here it's not just the money
that comes out of the blue States and
the money that you'll save here it
really is not it's the good people it's
the people who realize that they want
some autonomy over their lives and then
they move and they enrich the place they
go to and they leave the other one
they leave that Barren destitute land
where nothing's going to grow that's how
it is he continued a bit further on that
I can put money anywhere
anywhere why because the pandemic
changed our economy
40 percent of my staff at every company
regardless what city they're
headquartered in Works remotely that's
never going to change primarily in
accounting Logistics some marketing
positions certainly sales
you just don't need to be in the office
anymore I know there's guys trying to
get everybody back but you can see
through empty buildings in New York City
they're just not coming back they're
never going to they don't want to pay
those taxes but the point is they're
never going to yeah what happens to
Sixth Avenue
I think you turn it into condos because
people don't want to put the Nexus of
their business in a place
where AOC is telling you I hate you I'm
going to litigate you I'm going to sue
you I'm going to make sure that you
can't create a job my whole point is
there are go-to States
and there's no go States and no go
States right now are New York New Jersey
Massachusetts California
you cannot invest in those places they
are no longer investable they're going
to have to change policy have you been
to San Francisco
he probably could have included Illinois
in there and of course you know my
feelings on San Francisco like you
cannot do business in these places and
as things go more and more remote at the
end of the day if you're the head guy
running the business well you're going
to live in Florida and you're not going
to really care where your people live so
you might hire somebody that lives in
San Francisco but it's going to be
really expensive to live there and you
know this thing when Tucker asks about
what's going to happen on 6th Avenue
we're actually pre-taping tomorrow's
show because tomorrow night I'm going to
be on Gutfeld so I'm going to New York
tomorrow and I have to tell you the few
times that I've gone back to New York
since covet it's mostly been to do
Gutfeld and that's right in Midtown
Manhattan you know like 50th and
Broadway which is right by 6th Avenue
right over there and the it used to be a
place of business there were guys
walking around in suits women in pant
suits whatever it is doing business
people talking about business a city
that was flourishing and it all it does
now everyone's walking around solo head
down a lot of hoodies it smells like
weed there's nothing there and the
buildings everywhere lights off it is
deeply deeply depressing so you know he
said they'll turn it into condos I'll
actually go a step further I don't think
there'll be enough people moving in what
it's going to turn into is there will
they will bring Mass migrants there they
will turn hotels wait wait till you just
wait till the Saint Regis is a homeless
hotel but these are the policies these
people have so he's telling you he's
telling you
go to the promised land and that
promised land is probably right here
obviously it's probably in Texas it's
probably in Tennessee might be in
Montana might be in some other places
might be in South Dakota but it's not
those places so to my liberal friends to
bring us full circle my my liberal sane
friends
choice is yours you could keep saying
you're a good liberal and getting
everything wrong or
you can maybe go boy those scary people
are actually not that scary and they're
the ones doing the work to make sure
that I can still smoke my weed and
whatever else these people want to do uh
part one of my interview with Peter
Thiel that I just referenced is up right
now on YouTube and Rumble the full
things available ad free of course at
locals reubenport.locals.com where we'll
be doing a post-game show in about 47
seconds we leave you we didn't do much
on Biden today did I even say Biden did
I say Joe Biden once during the show we
leave you with ramblingly incoherent
Joe Biden and I'll see you in with the
post game in a sec and I'm a nurse named
Pearl Nelson military
she'd come in and do things that I don't
think you'll learn in medical school
Nursery School
she's whisper in my ear I didn't
couldn't understand him she wished when
she leaned down
you can actually breathe on me to make
sure that I was there was a connection
to human connection
she even went home and brought back her
pillow from her own bed because he
didn't do the one where I had that
wasn't comfortable
but I'm not joking
[Music]
foreign